hey I will be opening the subcommittee
the criminal justice subcommittee work
session on House Bill 470 FN relative to
fentel test trips and other jug drug
checking equipment if you could please
rise and join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance i al to United States of
America
thank you just going to take a brief
five minute
recess
e
I will now reopen criminal justice
subcommittee work session on House Bill
470 relative to fental test strips and
Other Drug checking
equipment uh I'd like to start off by
thanking everyone who's involved
representative Muse I know
representative nle
uh definitely put a lot into this again
as as I testified or spoke the last time
about this I think it's it's a really
good Bild to have however there's so
many back doors where the nefarious the
drug dealers and traffickers are going
to use this as a defense any defense
attorney is going to look at this bill
as is and use it for their behalf uh I
sat through for a week when I got the
the amendment and really looked at it
thoroughly and the only way that I feel
that this can go through
is to completely gut the bill and change
the wordage to prevent those unsavory
characters from using this as their
defense uh we do have the Fentanyl and
xylazine Bill that did go through which
is great I just think again as is that
there's too many loopholes where at its
face that wasn't the intent of the bill
but I think it is going to be used uh
for those nefarious
characters um we can vote on it today
obviously we'll hear some more testimony
uh it's probably going to go 33 and
we'll see how it goes again I just
really wish that this could be chopped
so much that we don't allow them to to
use the back door and this isn't a back
door this is back doors multiple doors
where they're going to sneak in uh
representative
selig thank you I I know that last time
we struggled with whether or not to meet
and I'm glad that we were able to have
the conversation then and you know I
didn't come in today with my mind made
up I came in today knowing we needed to
have the conversation and I hope that we
can all be here with that same energy
but I also was thinking as I drove over
here about the title of our committee
which is criminal justice which is how
we mostly refer to ourselves but there's
a significant other part of it which is
and Public Safety and so I'm I'm hopeful
that we can be looking at this bill not
just Through The Eyes of criminal
justice but really also um and probably
more so with the eyes of Public Safety
as we move forward and I I know that um
representative Muse has been working on
some amendments to try to help make the
language and the structure of the bill
more palatable and uh narrow the focus
so that it's not used by as as the term
you used I think was nefarious
characters which makes me think of the
minions but um you know sorry I'm a
parent um but I I just would say as we
move through today I really hope we can
be looking at all of this through the
focus of of public Public Safety and and
again as I said last time the goal is
one more day so that hopefully people
can recognize that that's the day they
should try to get into
recovery thank you representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman so um on our bail
uh last um committee meeting for ba uh
bail reform we had wonderful testimony
from this um Community member for out of
Manchester uh Jesus Lopez and he is an a
um former
um drug dealer um he came from the Bronx
settled in Manchester and he said that
um new and this is um this plays into
public safety he said that uh New
Hampshire people come to New Hampshire
because our drug our laws are so LAX um
and that he can get so much he could in
the past get so much more money for his
drugs in New Hampshire that we actually
attract um drugs and and and um dealers
after he you know gave his really
wonderful moving testimony he I asked
him I says do um substance misuse um
suffers actually test their um drugs for
fentanyl he said no I said should we um
uh legalize um nominal amounts of elicit
substances for testing he said no he
says because it
enables um addicts um and I have to
respect him because he's lived this this
is this was his life he spent 11 years
in um prison part of it was a federal
prison for being a drug uh um a drug um
dealer dealer thank thank you so I have
to listen to him and and you know and
his goal now is is to um keep people
safe and if he doesn't feel this is a
good idea I do not feel um that I can
upser his his testimony and say say uh
that I can support this thank
you thank you representative
Muse I think one of the things that we
we try to avoid on this committee is
legislating by anecdote um personal
stories are are powerful uh in the
context of the bail bills in the context
of this bill um we've heard some pretty
powerful stories along the way um one of
the things we also have our some pretty
powerful updated statistics so in nashaa
and Manchester so far this year American
Medical Response which is uh an
ambulance service has recorded uh has
responded to over 700 uh
overdoses and uh unfortunately quite a
few of those overdoses uh have been
fatal
overdoses and when asked to comment on
you know why we're still seeing uh these
high fatal overdose rates the regional
director of American response uh Medical
Response said people who are using
illicit substances have no idea what
they are using contain synthetic
fentanyl or how potent synthetic
fentanyl in the product is the people
who use these drugs are not necessarily
all drug dealers from the
Bronx um a lot of them are high school
kids they're college kids there are kids
there are parents there are husbands our
wives our daughters our
sons um and I think one of the things
that we need to to keep in mind um is
that the main objective of of this bill
um and also some of the proposals that
we've had to amend it what we're really
trying to do here are save lives I mean
that that's basically what it comes down
to um we not only have an overdose
problem in New Hampshire we have an
overdose fatality problem and there are
things that that we can do from a law
enforcement perspective that can help
um catching more drug dealers and
putting them in jail is a is a good
thing but I think one of the things that
we've learned over the past few years is
that we can do that we can support our
police in their efforts to do that um
and we should support our police and
their effort efforts to do that but I
think the other thing that we need to
look at is and we need to recognize is
that this issue is not just a criminal
justice problem it's also a public
health problem and and as a public
health problem one of the things that
you do is you look at things issues like
this through a slightly different lens
in in criminal justice we like to talk
about being able to prevent things uh
and changing the law you know to to
prevent people or disincentivize people
from from doing certain things in the
public health world one of the things
that we talk about is trying to actually
reduce the risk of bad things happening
I think we realize that nothing we do on
this committee no law we can pass is
going to ensure that people don't
continue to overdose on Fentanyl and
that some people won't continue to die
in from fentanyl but there are steps
that we can take by changing our law
that can help
ensure that fewer people are dying and
and and again we're not just talking
about drun drug leaders from the Bronx
or people from LOL and Lawrence the
people who are dying are people's Sons
daughters husbands wives um and this is
just something we have the power to do
that we have the power to act on um we
have a good bill in front of us uh that
would make it possible for more people
to be able to uh to check their drugs to
make sure that they don't contain
illicit substances or contain substances
that they don't even didn't even know
they were taking which is one of the
biggest problems with
fentanyl um and and I think that while
we made well we took an important step
uh in terms of legalizing uh f and
xylazine test strips uh if we really
want to achieve results in this area and
if we're really serious about reducing
the death rate
then this is the kind of Bill that we
need to pass and and and and I would
like to try to find a way we can come
together on
it thank you thank you excuse me just
real briefly and then uh represent and
pro uh looking through the law
enforcement lens which I was a state
police state trooper for for two decades
these bills criminals do not care about
otherwise they wouldn't be committing
crimes uh and I do appreciate yes we do
need to reduce these these deaths but
the the criminals do not care and what
this is doing is while we're now helping
the person who's addicted to test their
drugs we are now giving the criminal the
back door to use a defense to get them
back onto the streets to continue to
sell drugs that's why we really need to
chop this down if it goes forward uh and
again I do like it at its face but I'm
looking in my lens as law en and they
will use this for their defense and they
won't be locked up they'll get back onto
the streets and continue and continue
while more of the those who are addicted
are going to continue
to be addicted representative
Pro
so I work on the street as an
EMT I can't tell you how much Naran I've
given but I'm pretty
sure none of these people take the time
to test their drug drugs they get them
they take them and off they go and
that's uh I think has to do with them
overdosing is that they don't even
measure correctly or understand that if
they went from their old dealer to a ne
new dealer it's probably changed a
little bit and they should be cautious
they don't care they're just going to
take the same amount to get that high
and that's all they care about they're
not going to take out their little test
kit and say oh I got to test this see if
this F on there and frankly I I think
they might even like the fenil because
it gives them a better high and they're
you know playing craps with that is it
going to get me just higher or is it
going to push me over and hopefully if I
go over my friend has Naran in his
pocket and they'll take care of me but I
don't I don't see this as the answer the
way it's
written thank you
represent
so I'm looking at a 50st state survey
for the legality of drug checking
equipment in the United States and while
I can understand um that there might be
um that there could be some remote
possibility of someone using it as a
defense I'm really curious what this
information doesn't tell me and I'd love
to know is if when they passed uh
legalization of drug drug checking
equipment um defenses using this law
were used because I feel like we'd hear
about that I think that would be
something that um you know that people
would be up in arms about and and
rightly so if that were the case and I
just keep coming back to the the very
small amount that it is when we say
nominal nominal nominal when we say
nominal um and we're trying to make sure
that we restrict that as much as
possible I think you know the reason
we're doing that is so that we can allow
for the benefit in this one way and
protect against the potential for harm
um in in in another way so um I think
that's really what we've been trying to
do here is weigh the you know the
benefits and the potential for the
potential risks but also I mean just at
the end of the day I feel like we have
so much information to back up how this
is important and how this can be helpful
and so little evidence to the contrary
like that that the risks that people are
using it in cases and and I think you
know we as a body have a responsibility
to to look at the evidence as it as it
exists and and and not necessarily make
a decision based on um you know the the
worst possible well maybe somebody could
do this or whatever especially if we're
not seeing that happen you know so I can
understand the the concern about it but
some sometimes concerns don't really pan
out and I feel like what we've been
trying to do is trying to make it as
specific as possible so that we reduce
that risk while maintaining the
potential benefits for it
so thank you representative Reed the
representative Muse the represent of
celik thank you Mr chairman um substance
abuse Mis uh misuse disorders
progressively fatal very resistant to
treatment um generally people who are uh
have struggle with opioids um many of
them don't uh survive their addiction um
by making it
um I for a lack of a better word easier
I think that you know a a tough disease
needs needs to be dealt with on a
serious level I would like to see
statistics showing that how many lives
are saved due to testing you know I mean
I would like to see statistics and I'm
sure there's there are none out there
that um could support
uh life-saving life lives saved from
having available test drug testing
equipment that um would make me more
comfortable with the decision thank
you so back in February and March when
we were considering this bill um we
actually did hear a testimony from law
enforcement from uh State Police also
from the uh the chiefs of Police
Association and they expressed some of
the concerns that representative tenar
uh expressed as well so in response to
that one of the things that we did was
we did draft an amendment uh that we
were going to talk about uh during our
executive session but we decided given
the fact that the fentanyl test strips
Bill had had passed uh we decided to uh
to retain this bill so we never were
able to propose the amendment one of the
things that I've handed out to members
of the committee is uh uh essentially a
marked up copy of the original Bill uh
with the amendment text uh included in
there and the amendment text uh uh
addresses things like some of the
concerns around uh uh packaging uh and
repackaging and making it clear that
these things that you know we're talking
about it in the context of drug checking
only not in the terms of not in terms of
uh manufacturing or Distributing uh
these
chemicals um we added uh language uh
defining uh a nominal amount uh because
frankly you have to have some level of
uh of these illicit drugs available to
actually be able to uh to do any type of
a test uh the uh I I think one of the
other things that we also need to pay
attention to are some things that have
sort of flown under the radar a little
bit um so one of the things that's uh
been going on in this field is uh there
have been some companies that have been
uh developing uh potentially more
effective versions of
nxone uh and because our control Drug
Act only specificly names Noone there
could be a potential issue with being
able to use some of these new and
improved agents to actually help people
who are um you know who actually do
overdose so there are some things like
that that are that are baked into the
amendment as well we also would have to
do things like change uh the effective
date which I think is now June uh June
uh 2023 so he can't go back in time so
we need to go forward in time one thing
that I I would just suggest to we we
have uh Lauren McGinley here who uh
testified uh originally in favor of the
bill uh who can answer just specific
questions that we may have around the
amendment of uh actually a lot of the
suggestions for uh for the amendment
text uh came from Miss McGinley uh and
uh uh and from Carrie nry who also works
in the harm reduction field here in New
Hampshire uh so it'd be great to hear
from them uh at uh at whatever Point uh
the chair feels it would be appropriate
to do
that thank you representative Cel thank
you I definitely agree with with
representative Muse and just I remember
last week when we were leaving um my
recollection is that you had talked
about amend we had been working from an
amendment that representative Muse had
prepared last year that we hadn't used
um
2023-the and I just wasn't sure if that
had been if that had happened or if that
you'd made a different decision and just
if I could understand where we got from
the end of our last meeting where there
was going to be a potential amendment
that we could work through
to we don't want to move forward at all
and I'm I'm just trying to to make the
two things make sense in my head thank
you yes we had that kind of Quasi
agreement to look at this to change the
language but as I sat down and read the
full Bill and this was literally a week
of me like going back to it I was like a
madman if you will trying to figure out
how can we make this work uh based upon
what uh representative Newman had kind
of suggested to the committee and the
more I looked at it the more I thought
that the the back doors were opening
more and more and more and I wanted us
to talk further about it because I would
and in my law enforcement background and
uh through my degrees with criminal
justice and law looking at this it would
have had to been completely slash so I
did kind of make that almost 180ish uh
so I hope that answers your
question uh I'll call uh Miss is Lauren
McGinley am I on okay hi good morning
everyone uh so I'm Lauren McGinley I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire harm reduction Coalition as
representative Muse mentioned I work
very closely with Dr Niti out of unh
associate professor of nursing but also
project manager on the Hera project harm
reduction education and technical
assistance together the harm reduction
Coalition and hereda have worked closely
um
over uh the span of about three years
now covering all of New Hampshire and
kind of analyzing regions for Readiness
availability and current status of many
harm reduction
strategies mat or M availability that's
medication assisted treatment or
recovery
Avail availability Noone availability
all the way deep into um very specific
harm reduction strategies like syringe
availability drug checking fentanyl test
strips things like that um so I'm happy
to answer any questions I've also been
very very lucky to um be invited by
brandise University who has a drug user
Health um Department led by Dr Tracy
green she has helped the state of
Massachusetts set up very specific drug
checking sites within their harm
reduction programs these are Community
level like street level programs that
invite their participants to come in
receive health related Services
counseling relative to HIV hepc testing
um counseling related to mat or M
treatment as well as do comprehensive
drug checking which is what we're
talking about today I was able to go in
and with witness um how those programs
operate with such a uh in my head up
until seeing it it was a very scientific
process because we kept using the word
math spectrometer so I couldn't really
understand how it was delivered at a
community level street level um but it
was really wonderful to see the flow of
people coming in and engaging and
utilizing this service so I'd be happy
to answer questions as they come
up thank you I just I have one question
I know you're there brief did you see
the same people over and over again or
is there any way to track was this
program actually helping them um so I
did not see them but our the chemist
that uh was doing the testing at two of
the sites he um greeted people said
hello to them seemed to know them so it
seemed to be something that they
utilized often um I know that one person
in a Lawrence program had been coming in
for about 5 years years um and had been
really excited when they started to have
this because he wanted to be able to
communicate out to his friends in his
own Community what was happening with
the drug Supply um he said he had been
doing this for a long time and um had
not
seen such an impact that the the current
drug Supply had been making I'm trying
to keep all the swears out of what he
said um so yeah so he had seen he he had
he had not seen such negative impact
from the drug Supply as he had seen in
the last five
years thank you representative
n thank you um I just wanted to kind of
make sure emphasize a certain part of
what you said and a lot of what we're
we're talking about is you know like I
was just saying the the um potential
risks and the benefits right and I think
that there's a lot in the benefits that
isn't
necessarily um that that is a little
more
uh obscure right that kind of goes under
the Wayside and one of the things that
you mentioned and one of the things that
I've read a lot about when we're talking
about um testing centers and things like
that is the ability at that point to
engage with folks right to build
relationships with people to build trust
which you know so I I'll let you take it
from there I just wonder if you could
focus a little bit on that because I
feel like that's something that we don't
necessarily recognize as one of the
potential benefits with it and how that
contributes to the overall um you know
IDE a of of um increasing people's um
chances of of successful recovery yeah
yeah so I mean I just a little tiny bit
of History prior to this I worked in
direct case management with individuals
um with substance use disorder primarily
parenting um mothers parenting or
pregnant mothers um I had no knowledge
of harm reduction um with the exception
of what my public health education had
taught me so a very surface level um
being in a very traditional case
management setting I had my binder full
of protocol and and how you know when
somebody said this this is what I did
when somebody said this this is what I
did and when they tested positive for a
drug in their system I was no longer
able or allowed to work with them I had
to exit them from my programming um the
burnout that happens in those situations
is very extreme when you feel like uh a
positive drug test means that I can no
longer I no longer have tools to help
that individual so when I moved into
harm reduction I was really really Blown
Away by the agency that we give back to
the people that we work with in all of
those
situations when someone comes to me and
asks for sterile syringes and a safe
injection kit the agency that is given
back to them to be able to say I am
identifying to you the things that I
need and I'm able to provide them to
them a whole new level of communication
has opened up between me and the the
person that I am serving because I don't
have to stop the conversation it's not a
question that I need to get past with
them are you using drugs or not so
really it leaves all of this space and
room for deeper more authentic
conversations to be happening around how
to keep them safe if they are using
drugs and that's where I think you're
correct the Nuance is there um I I will
say from my own experience in the past
three years um fentanyl test strips and
xylazine test strips are utilized every
single day by people who use drugs um I
will tell you that the most positive
population to utilize fentanyl test
strips and xylazine test strips are
college age children College age young
adults I probably shouldn't call them
children um because that is a population
who has decided they are going to use a
very specific drug and they are no
longer interested in using any other
drug that might be contaminating that
one drug for instance cocaine is a
recreational drug commonly found on
college campuses if a a young adult has
decided that they are going to use
cocaine they are no longer interested in
utilizing that when it tests positive
for fentanyl or xylazine so that's a
population where I think people are
seeing the exact desired results of
fentanyl test strips and xylazine test
strips that's the kind of the extreme
reaction to utilizing them but I will
say in a year we have distributed by
request over 80 ,000 fentanyl test
strips in our um programming so I hope
they're being utilized because they're
very expensive and and people are asking
quite loudly for them so um we we hear
from people across the the the age
spectrum that they are utilizing the the
fentanyl test stps with every new batch
that they are purchasing um because we
don't currently have the supply
available for people to use them every
single time they use a drug but with
each new B match their testing and now
we have a a whole team of participants
that are really engaged in not only
utilizing the xylazine test strips but
in helping the companies that make them
make them better because there are some
smaller flaws with the xylazine test
strips um and so you know again it's
it's returning that agency back to a
population where previously I had
removed their agency many times um and
seeing that engagement has really led to
deeper conversations around
safety thank you representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman it it's very
promising to hear the success you're
having for sure um I just it seems how
would changing our current statue change
your success I mean it seems like it's
working why would we have to change
something that's not broken sure thank
you it's a great question because um I
look at this as like we are uh
um we're working with a picture of our
drug Supply and when we passed when we
successfully passed Fentanyl and xine
test strip legality our picture became
slightly clearer not clear at all we
still can't see it it's still a major
blind spot in public health but we're
starting to clear up that picture a
little bit what we would like to do from
a public health perspective is be able
to have a consistent and dynamic
constantly changing picture of what the
current drug Supply looks like because
New Hampshire is um uniquely situated
between some large um entry corridors of
substances coming in Boston has large
ports Canadian border is not far away um
and so we don't have a clear picture of
what's currently happening with our drug
Supply in New Hampshire therefore our
reactions like fentanyl test strips
xylazine test strips or nxone are only
as good as the things that we have
already identified existing within our
supply my concern is that
fentanyl was fentanyl was a GameChanger
in
preventing um overdose deaths that was
that that changed the game for all of us
doing this
work we could have
seen the need for increased or different
strategies around overdose prevention if
we had acknowledged or known that
fentanyl had been in the supply in the
the um in the quantities that it was
starting to appear in not only
quantities but in the drugs that it was
starting to appear in that that was
really where we kind of tripped up was
fentanyl started appearing in Supply
that we didn't know fentanyl was going
to be in so my concern is what will be
our next Fentanyl and we're going to
have to lean very very heavily on
programs that are in Massachusetts
programs that are in Rhode Island
programs that are nearby but are not
exact replicas of what New Hampshire's
drug Supply looks like in the way that
we approach our next xylazine or our
next fentanyl we will always be behind
the times because we can only start to
react to it once we know it's in the
supply thank you followup thank you so
um we already people are allowed to use
xylazine and Fentanyl test strips you I
heard you say you have access to a
spectrometer with a chemist no no sorry
I I don't um the programs um within some
of yeah so there is there is um testing
available currently to test random
samples of street that drugs that are on
the street currently for whatever is new
and novel in the drug Supply no not in
New Hampshire in Massachusetts
Massachusetts has um comprehensive drug
checking so that's where I went okay so
we don't have um spectrometers um
wouldn't that fall under your licensing
your health agency licensing umbrella no
it does not currently so it doesn't
protect my staff um or myself from
having these machines or being able to
do this testing in partnership with our
participants the people that we serve
and is there any Les um is there any
communication with the state toxicology
lab sure um is our samples sent there
for um testing to see what's on the
market on the street thank you sure yeah
so uh we've had a long conversation with
the state public health labs they do
have some of the Machinery that you
would need but to be very I will give a
very quick overview these machines are
called ftir machines ftirs are loaded
with a brain so you can buy a brain
that's relative to Art you can buy a
brain that's relative to algae we would
need to purchase a brain relative to
drugs and Drug
contaminants um so right now it doesn't
have the brain that I think that we the
most comprehensive brain that we would
need it to have also receiving the
samples is where the legality issue
comes in um so a small tiny amount of
substance in fact I've purchased little
Scoops if anybody would like to see the
um size that you would need to to create
a successful or to to run a successful
test um to receive those is where we're
running into our legality issues our
participants aren't able to come to us
with the um half a grain of rice of
Supply that they would would need to um
have a test done and currently the
methodology for how the state public
health lab is acquiring samples to chest
our drug Supply is incredibly backlogged
and is not coming from Supply channels
that would
indicate current drug Supply um and I
can explain a little bit more if people
want to know why it's not current drug
Supply I'm seeing that okay so so
currently right now we have a dropped
powder um policy in the state so if a
dropped powder is found at the scene of
a crime not relating to substance or
drug trafficking dealing um then that
dropped powder would be able to enter
into state public health um
lab um pool for testing but that doesn't
mean that the drop powder like the day
somebody picks it up off the ground and
then enters it into the state public
health lab that that's when it would be
tested they actually have a very very
long list of things that are going to
need to go through this ftir or mass
speec machine um to to so there's a a
serious backlog additionally that's not
indicative of what our current drug
Supply is because these drugs can't be
utilized from any scene where known
substance use was happening an overdose
occurred anything like that um so why
that powder was sitting at the team the
the scene who it came from why it was
there and and when it had most recently
been used or even purchased is
completely unknown so again it's another
picture that is very very blurry it is
giving us some idea of what could be
coming in and out of New Hampshire what
could exist or had existed but it's not
um well curated data and it's definitely
not well-shared data we have a great
relationship with the state public
health lab but even they know the
limitations of this dropped powder
thank you representative appr so why
does it have to be drop powder and not
something found at a scene or
active yeah I completely agree I think
one of the biggest missing um pieces of
data would be substances found at the
scene of a fatal overdose I would love
to see our state enter into um an
agreement to begin testing um that um
I think that dropped powder would be the
one that probably avoids I would need
you know um we have legal Consultants
here but um I would assume drop powder
probably uh prevents any of the evidence
from being contaminated by testing or
being removed from the scene
specifically for testing so because that
drop powder was not evidence none of the
crimes are related to it I would assume
it's kind of like it can just be
utilized for a public health testing
I just know again based on my my
experience it seems like there's two
different Labs there's the State Health
lab and then there's the crime lab state
police crime lab so they're they're
probably not talking to each other and
there's what you're talking about the
drop Potter would never go probably to
the state police crime lab it would be
me as a trooper stopping a car whatever
and I find drugs that then goes to the
the state police crime lab uh sure yeah
and you're you are correct I actually
don't have any interaction with the um
police crime labs and um the again the
dispersement of information from them is
not coming into the public health
programs that respond to drug related
harms representa
Muse so so one of the things that that
actually might be helpful I know in the
beginning with the fentanyl test strips
bill um uh it it was narrowed down just
to fentanyl test strips but it was
actually expanded uh uh later on so that
xylazine was added
um one of the things you said that's
really interesting is is I think a lot
of folks tend to focus on harm reduction
as basically being something that can
benefit an an individual drug user but
the fact that uh if you actually take
all of this information and put it
together um especially in a way that's
that's more immediate than what some of
the other drug testing Labs can provide
it can actually provide a picture of of
where
contaminants um and bad pills so for
instance pills that people think are
Oxycodone that are actually fentanyl it
can provide a picture of where where are
they entering you know the the
marketplace are there parts of the State
uh that are more affected uh than other
parts of the state you know what what's
the overall picture you know in terms of
the penetration of a contaminant like
xylazine so
one of the things I that I find
interesting is we're we're not just
we're not getting that information just
by handing people out fentanyl test
strips um and I and I think one of the
things I wanted to point out to to my
colleagues is that um you know to be
honest my bill 470 the one that we're
considering today basically started out
as an attempt to do what representative
nesville did um my goal was just to
legalize fent test strips because I
thought it was kind of crazy that we
didn't have a tool like that that was
legally available for people um and uh
fortunately I had uh several
conversations uh with Miss McGinley and
Miss no who who basically explained to
me that there's there's an opportunity
here uh to actually impact far more
people in a in a positive way and one of
the things that I would say is that if
we if we put this bill side if we if we
don't do anything with it there are some
things in here you know for example one
of the things that we do in the in the
bill is we actually Define drug checking
in the context of our uh of our control
Drug Act so we actually make it part of
that so so so one of the things that we
actually did with representative newes
bill is we managed to actually legalize
Fen fentanyl test strips without saying
that drug checking is necess you know is
is legal and is an activity that we
should be pursuing from a policy
perspective so there are some I I think
that there are a lot of good things uh
in this bill um there may be some ways
that uh that we can tighten it up in you
know in ways that uh I I would hope
would be acceptable to the law
enforcement Community because I think
they're just as interested is anybody in
this room when it comes to minimizing um
you know fatalities from overdose
but I I would just hate to see um an
opportunity to to
actually address part of this crisis in
a meaningful way go by the boards for at
least another year um
while we're still in the middle of an
opioid
crisis so I I'm just kind of hoping that
we can uh we can find a way to come
together on
this thank you repres representative C
giv it a question from Miss McGinley yes
okay and is it all right if I ask a
series of questions that sort of they
build on each other yes okay thank you
thank you thank you so much um so my
first question is do you know about what
year it was that fentanyl first was
introduced into New
Hampshire I I don't um I don't because
we can't trust our drug Supply so right
I'm unable if if you had a guess would
you say five years ago 10 years 15 years
no um I 15
Ma and then maybe more okay so it's 10
to Sure 10 to 15 I don't know I'm so
sorry no that's okay so so again if
there had
been broader-based ruling allowing for
drug
testing 10 years ago we might have maybe
been able to identify fenol entering our
drug Supply then to take action against
it is that correct uh yes and if I could
add really quick quickly a a great
example of this is actually xylazine um
xylazine has been in the drug supply for
an unknown period of time but
unfortunately has probably been costing
hospitals um and insurance entities a
substantial amount of money before it
was ever even identified why people were
developing such terribly infected and
hardt treat wounds so that is a great
example of um we did not know what was
happening even our population of people
who use drugs did not know what was
happening um but had been seen multiple
times for severely infected wounds um
which could have easily if we had known
was in the supply been linked to
xylazine which is what xylazine causes
in humans and so
just thinking about that so we now have
the ability to test for those two
specific substances yes only within our
drug yes
um um if you had to guess and I
recognize this is pure
speculation of what of um a number of
other substances being introduced into
our narcotic Supply and I'm not
suggesting we should be encouraging
narcotic Supply I want to be very clear
about that but if if you had to guess
how many things do you think could be in
our current narcotic Supply that we
don't know are there because we can't
test it sure um so for concerning
substances in the current drug Supply
the two that kind of rattle around in my
head as our next big con tenders um one
is an ongoing problem but I think is
going to increase substantially is benzo
diazines being entered into the heroin
Supply
um benzodiazapines um is a withdrawal
that somebody can die from um so even if
we have somebody entering into treatment
and detoxing not knowing that benzo
Asians might be in their system or in
their drug supply for as long as a year
two years three years we don't know what
their benzodiazapine you know has
exposure has been like that to me is
very concerning um additionally um Le
levam Leva missile is a new contaminant
that's starting to show up in
Massachusetts um this is going to cause
serious wounds the same way that
xylazine is but these wounds are going
to create deeper abscesses into the
tissue which um is going to it's a whole
bigger Beast currently xylazine wounds
resemble and kind of react like Burns
severely like third degree
burns um these wounds are going to be
much deeper into the tissue sometimes
into the muscle um some bone infections
things like that it it's not these are
not going to be wounds that are going to
be able to be treated at street level
with some of our own wound treatment
Specialists that go out to people so
those are two substances right off the
bat that I would love to know the
saturation in New Hampshire and and what
that is going to start to look like
thank you I've got one last one and then
so you know obviously it's wonderful
that we can now test for the two
substances right yeah um I'm just
curious as I read the original intent of
this and even the amend potential
amendments to this version it's really
about creating space so that as our
knowledge of um of the drug Supply
changes things can have a quick pivot to
to test for things to hopefully prevent
um I mean not just harm reduction but
also to help bring awareness to things
you know like I think about when car
fenel which is an elephant tranquilizer
started getting introduced on top of
fenel into a number of things I'm not
sure what the status of car fenel is at
the moment and if that shows up in fenel
test strips or not I don't it's beyond
my level of knowledge um but I'm just
curious if if that resonates with you
that the idea would be that this would
allow us a way to Pivot quickly to test
for things that we don't know that we
don't know about yet because they're not
here yet yes yeah
um in public health I think the scariest
thing um for you is what you don't know
I don't know what I don't know and that
that unknown is what is scariest to me
because it took us a while to build
strategies mostly in part with people
who use drugs around preventing Serious
injury and fatalities related to
xylazine but that turn around time from
being able to acknowledge that it's in
the drug Supply to having some really
successful strategies to limit the harms
of it um was not short it it wasn't what
we wanted it to be so um not having um
blank test strips so originally um you
know representative new's bill was for
any rapid testing strip that would have
been um successful for us because as we
speak about four different types of rap
rapid test strips are being created for
distribution to Public Health
departments we won't be able to utilize
them because the bill was limited at
some point in its lifespan here but
um you know we can look to our other
states around us to see what they're
starting to see what we're not going to
be able to see is a their pathway
through the state and how they're
impacting different regions much more
harshly than some and then we won't be
able to see what is here that isn't in
Massachusetts what's here that isn't in
Rhode Island
um thank you representative Reed sure
thank you Mr chair would this better be
addressed with a policy change a
communication between the state lab and
the criminal the uh what was the crime
lab the crime lab can there be like a
communication between the three of you I
think that that would be a a good step
in uh um kind of like a detour direction
to putting together what we currently
have and utilizing the most of that um
what we would love to see though is a
much wider pool of data so if we're only
using powders found at specific crime
scenes we still not you know the amount
of people that would come in and have
their substances tested or they found
these and now would like to have them
tested we would just see such a a bigger
pool of data thus clearing our picture
much much more um so in the days that I
went to drug testing programs about 25
to 30 tests were done each day that I
was there um and that is happening seven
days a week in Massachusetts so they're
just their picture is becoming more and
more clear with more
samples thank you representative n um
Miss McKinley um mentioned that she has
Scoops that give the amount would it be
okay for me to hand those out pass them
around so we can see yes thank you sure
yeah so 10 milligrams is a difficult um
I think that was maybe what the the
measurement that was decided upon in a
limit in the bill oh sorry you can have
the whole bag they're all for
you um because sometimes we take a 10
milligram pill every day or we take a 20
milligram pill and we see that pill in
our hand and we think that's a giant
amount um but you know the milligrams on
the medications that we take is a
concentration level and not a
measurement so this measurement is the
max amount that would be needed and
would be um necessary to to do this
earlier in in this bill when it was up
for discussion it was thought that
perhaps people who deal drugs would now
break their drug Supply up into 10
milligram baggies that's not the case as
you can see that's not the case and
would be impossible to do so I just
wanted to give a solid visual of what we
were looking
at thank you and I do appreciate this
because that was my thought that the
deers would continue to break it up into
hundreds of thousands of little
milligrams and say look I just have my
little testing supply so I do appreciate
this sure in fact most tests are
actually done um with the residue in a
cooker or a cotton or a residue of a
baggie that people are bringing in most
people are not bringing in their
substance they're bringing in something
with residue and we're more than able to
do a test um with any of
those thank you any other
questions thank you so much I appreciate
this sure thank
you so I think we've heard a great
amount of testimony and some good back
and forth with my uh fellow
Representatives we might just now be
going in a circle uh I'd ask if anyone
wishes to provide a motion at this time
go go ahead represent S I just I see
that we do have other people in the room
I didn't know if any of them like have a
specific thing that we you know I know
we heard testimony earlier in the year
but as we're doing this today if there's
someone who's maybe brought some
information that we are not aware that
we don't know um before we continue and
then I also wonder whether there's
openness to developing an amendment at
all that would allow us to to move
forward with something to allow for
additional harm reduction measures
especially since I had to borrow
representative new's readers in order to
see the bottom of the
scoop it's there I trust me I can see it
just for now uh is there anyone else
that would like to speak and uh
representative
selig I would like to put this to vote
but in the interim before we get it back
to the committee if anyone would want to
develop an amendment and this is where I
this extra time I think that if I can
gut it to present my own Amendment and
maybe representative musef take whatever
we said today and tweak yours a little
bit I think that would be great I'm
definitely open for the Amendments I
just don't want to see it to completely
die but as is for me maybe others up
here that I I can't I can't go with this
right now is there anyone else that
wishes to speak sir maybe you could just
state your name when you come
up my name is Jason
Blackburn um I don't have any new
information to add um the woman that
spoke before for me is very highly
knowledgeable um I just have a little
bit of a personal statement that I
wanted to make um my name is Jason
Blackburn um well excuse me let me back
up honorable representatives of the
State of New Hampshire my name is Jason
Blackburn and I am a person in long-term
recovery I currently work in Behavioral
Health on the front lines of substance
use and psychiatric
challenges I've been in recovery from
substance use for 15 years in that time
I have lost count at the number of
people I have cared about that have lost
their lives from
overdose Halloween night
2013 I came home to find my best friend
and roommate Eden overdosed in the
bathroom I performed chest compressions
on him until EMS
arrived they did all they
could this Halloween will Mark the 10th
year he has been gone I firmly believe
that fentel played a part in his is
death the current state of the drug
Supply in this whole country is
toxic having the ability to test drugs
can save a life items such as Fentanyl
and xylazine test strips are harm
reduction tools not drug
paraphernalia just as much as noxin and
sterile syringes are all harm reduction
tools are necessary components of
battling the ongoing overdose EP
epidemic why very simply put no one can
attempt to begin to embrace substance
use recovery if they are
dead noxin saves lives sterile syringes
save lives fentel and xylazine test
strips save lives thank you for allowing
me the time to speak
today thank you so
much
uh there's been a requests for a caucus
so a brief five minute
recess
we will now be reopening the criminal
justice subcommittee work session on
House Bill
470 and
I representative Reid for a
motion um thank you Mr chairman I vote
to itl the bill I'll second the motion
seconded by representative
PR representative Reed do you wish to
speak upon your motion I do um we I this
was a very hard decision to come to
because the public safety aspect of
testing is critical and very and um
Paramount I um struggle with all the um
nebulous areas of of the bill and the
amendment that allows
um a lot of um potential abuse so um
that is the only reason I suggest
itl represent Pro uh I'm in the same
predicament right so I think there's a
lot of good to testing and we need to
make that work but we also in this need
to close the backd doors and I'm hoping
uh between my colleagues and and you
guys over there that we can get a better
amendment to close some of those things
especially like on this last page
so and then I'm off of this right and
and I think one of the things I would
really like to find out
is in Massachusetts in Rhode Island I
believe is where it's
happening do they have a back door
that's being abused and or did they find
a way to close it so I would like to
look at that and maybe put that in our
Amendment if it's working down there and
how they get it to work down there
without this uh and I was really glad
that you brought me that uh spoon to
really visualize you know I know what it
is but to see it in in that little
amount and tell me that yeah sometimes
we just use the residue from the bag
that they have uh was very helpful to
get my head around
this
so because you know I would really like
to pass it and say well if the back door
gets abused we could close it later but
I know that never happens never happens
or it's very hard to get that to happen
because once it's gone through it just
nobody wants to look at it again and try
and fix it so I think we need to fix it
right here right now before it goes to
our full committee for a vote and then
we can look at it
there thank you that's I agree with
everything my colleagues on this side
said we want this to work we probably
will have a couple weeks for this to get
back to Committee in the meantime maybe
you guys do a further Amendment we'll
figure something out we do want this to
work we really do uh but we just don't
want to close the back door and we want
to help
people survive and live we don't want to
see anyone perish because of this this
this disease represent of
Cel thank you so much I I think I'm
confused procedurally um because you're
talking about it Ling re making an itl
recommendation which would kill the bill
and making an amendment and if it's itl
there's no point to an amendment and so
my understanding of the process and
again I'm new and so perhaps one of our
more experienced members
um Can clarify the process um but um my
understanding is the purpose of us
having the subcommittee is so that we
can hash out the details so that we
would provide a joint amendment that
would be from all of us or the majority
of us to address this rather than voting
because if we end up with a 3 three tie
we have no recommendation but then if
we're coming with different amendments
I'm not I'm having a I guess for me I'm
having a hard time seeing these
nefarious back doors it feels to me like
like being afraid of the boogeyman
rather than
having and and again that's that's my
how I'm just hearing it and I'm not
suggesting that's where we're going I
recognize that there's concerns about
drug dealers using things I think
there's easy ways to address that
although I'd also rather if drug dealers
weren't delivering these dangerous
substances and if that's the issue then
we just figured that out but I I just
procedurally I'm very confused by the
motion to itl and then the talk of
amending um
so thank you the boogeyman is real and
they do show up and I've been there and
I've seen the boogeyman uh I would like
to as the chair think of how it is
procedurally and I'll definitely refer
to representative Muse after my belief
is this is a recommendation to the
committee it will be brought to the
committee the committee can then hear
further amendments in that committee uh
we would then vote on it it would then
either go to the house maybe without a
recommendation we could even still amend
it before we vote on it in the house
that is my understanding of it and
definitely representative Muse correct
me if I'm wrong it happens a
lot oh that and that's okay it's taken
me three terms to actually catch on to
some of this my stuff myself but um as a
subcommittee um we have several
different ways we can go one is we can
make no recommendation at all then what
happens is the bill goes back to the
full committee and people just vote
wherever the the chips May lie
um we can recommend um itl um and if itl
is the recommendation of the you know
majority uh of of the committee then the
committee would vote the full committee
would vote on the itl
recommendation um but because it's an
itl recommendation no Amendment would be
possible uh in committee what would be
possible would be uh a a floor Amendment
if we if we kind of fought it on the
fought it on the floor so if we had an
itl recommendation
um what one of the options for us would
be to oppose the itl recommendation on
the floor and also to include a floor
Amendment you know which realistically I
don't think is the way we want to do
this thing I think what we'd rather do
is to try to come together on some kind
of an amendment so the the other thing
that we can do is we can work together
on an amendment we can vote on on an
amendment um one of the things that we
can do is we you know to kind of get
there sort of what I tried to do today
which was to take the previous Amendment
and sort of show you in a marked up
msword version what it kind of looks
like in the original bill um and then
what we would do you know once we kind
of agree on the parameters of of of an
amendment is we would go back to uh
legislative services and legislative
Services would actually create um a
formal amendment that we would vote on
in a subcommittee so what we would would
do if we created an amendment would be
our recommendation back to the full
committee would be ought to pass with
Amendment um and then the full committee
would would would vote on that and and
as always we vote on them separately so
the committee would first have to pass
the amendment and then we would have to
we'd have to pass the Bill uh as
Amendment an an option for the full
committee um and I'm I'm not 100% sure
if this is an option for us from a
recommendation perspective but one of of
the things that you can do with a bill
in the second year is to uh is to
recommend it go to interim
study um and so
realistically interim study can be sort
of a nicer way to kill a bill um but I
think one of the things uh you know to
note is that we've actually had some
success on our committee of actually
sent remanding a bill to interim study
um discussing it and then recommending
it for future
legislation the the problem with interim
study is you know when you're in a
situation where there's a crisis and
we're looking to do things to make
things better all we all we can really
do at the end of that is make a
recommendation for a future legislature
to pass a bill like this we're not
actually passing the legislation
ourselves so essentially what it means
is a year delay in in in doing something
so what I would say if there's if
there's willingness to to work together
on an amendment um so we can move this
thing forward I would love to do
that thank you representa re I agree I
would but I would want to go line by
line together okay and then once we
agree line by line that's the amendment
we we present to um Os or yeah legal
services and that's right and I mean you
know based on experience with this um I
I think that when there's Goodwill on
the side of you know both parties we can
actually go through a process like that
to to do it and it also gives us the
opportunity to kind of go through things
that um like the rationale for some
things um you know being xed out of the
original Bill and other things other
things appearing and I I think a in
large part what we're trying to do with
this bill isn't necessarily to uh you
know create you know big drug checking
centers you know like like they have in
some states but I think what we're
trying to do is we're trying to get drug
checking into the into the control Drug
Act we're trying to eliminate a
situation where public health
professionals can actually be charged
with a crime of you know for helping
with jug checking and things like that
which is a possibility now um and most
important of all we're we're trying to
make a dent in these overdose
fatalities understood but I mean um look
at Oregon you know Washington um
Philadelphia New York they're all fa
colossal failures we have to be able to
to do better um all
around and you know and I think that
this need we need to look at this and
protect this the the person on the
street um but not have that happen we
don't want to deal with Oregon
Washington New York Philadelphia of San
Francisco we don't want that for New
Hampshire just
interrupt uh we we're definitely in
agreement we're going to work together
uh because it's seems like we're both of
us are all having like the uh the
testimony again my concern was that we'd
run out of time uh do you know the time
restraints that we have to get this back
to committee I know it was November uh
does anyone know the time limits when we
have to get this back Brad do you
know
no
so we have
time so that would be the Brad the full
committee recommendation has is due by
the 17th of November
yep thank thank you so much so I guess
what we'll do is that gives us time I
was confused I thought we had to get
this right out and then we would itl it
and then try to throw in our our motions
uh excuse me our amendments but
representative Muse thank you for
filling Us in everyone is in agreement
that we're going to meet up down the
road I know we don't want to keep coming
back but we this is something where all
of us really want to make this happen
representative
Cel said what would you be open to
withdrawing the I I'm gonna withdraw my
second right now sorry I'm
just we're we're slowly getting into
where we all know it uh would uh
representative Reed like to resend her
motion uh yes I will resend my itl and
representative appr your second I
withdrew it withdrew on okay so go ahead
so I'm I'm wondering whether we even
right now can start working through some
of the language or if you want to have a
sub
sub whatever how whatever number it is
sorry my words are a little messy um but
to to work out like whether there's a
way we can bang the language round back
and forth to get this to an acceptable
place and then meet again next you know
give ourselves till next week maybe to
work on language that we can all try to
work to agree to and then create an
amendment or for my scheduling purposes
I will not unfortunately be able to do
that today but if we can plan all of us
together to plan maybe a 5 hour day not
saying we will but we can all put it
together bang heads and then we can work
it out and then we'll get our vote
hopefully all 60 OTP uh representative
Muse what I would suggest is that we all
go through um the marked up version that
I included today if there are I can send
that to people electronically as well
and I'll do that just so you have you
all have copies of it what I would
suggest is if there are areas in there
that are problematic for you Circle them
and then just jot down really quickly
why it's problematic for you as we're
going through the bill one of the things
that we can do is we can talk about
those areas but I think one of the
things that's important from a process
standpoint is not necessarily letting an
early bump in the road keep us from
having a robust discussion about the
entire bill so if there's something that
it looks like we're not agreeing on one
of the things that I find with
legislation is that sometimes if you
just keep talking um and you and you
start to address other issues some kind
of a solution to the earlier impass can
sometimes make itself available um and
so what I would suggest that we do is
rather than letting anything like that
become an impediment to us doing
anything um we just put it in a parking
lot and we move on to the next thing and
uh and then at the end we revisit the
things that we need to revisit and try
to come to agreement on those as well
but but but to me that that seems like a
good process for um you know for getting
to a better place just a reminder that
we can't be legislating in private right
why we have to have open meetings so we
can put I'm thinking like my view is I
don't like this and we can decide to to
create an amendment with that whoever is
writing it but then we need to really
discuss why this and
that here right so I can look at this
and say I want this out and that for an
amendment but I think that's as far as
we can go one of the things that we I
believe we do have the ability to do
would be to cockus on things so you guys
can cockus and we can caucus yes and so
we can't cockus together that's right or
and I can't I can't uh I I can't you
know meet Jeff at Dunkin Donuts and work
it out there I mean we can't do that
stuff have it on camera and they can
view US yeah but but one of the one of
the things that we we we can do or my
understanding is that we can develop
caucus proposals um and something like
that may actually help because some
sometimes I find that even you know even
working among among my fellow Dems just
sort of just aggress just being able to
address points that we're not quite
understanding the same way uh can be
really helpful just to kind of getting
us all on the same page so I think I
think that's something um that could be
done it's not a
and what it and what it would not do is
preclude any member of the committee
from basically saying whatever they want
or you know expressing the fact that
they may not agree with a particular
change everybody else is set with and um
but it it is important that um you know
this is a public meeting and we are
supposed to be doing this out in the
open as much as possible and I and I
think we need to respect
that so represents representative selig
I just was going to say in terms of
meeting next week I could do Tuesday
Wednesday or Thursday schedule wise um I
can't do Monday or Friday but I can do
any of the three in between Halloween or
second that's correct I I
just I have things on on the bracket
days I absolutely can't
do Wednesday definitely not I have small
children and I have to be the The Candy
Man you mean Tuesday's Halloween so for
for my town uh Pelham we do it always on
Halloween uh I know some towns do it
like on the weekends or whatever uh and
I I do plan on us being here for at
least a couple hours to really bang this
out and you know see what we're going to
put together and then we can go to OS
get that Amendment and hopefully we vote
it out as an OTP 60 so we're looking at
the first WN we can do Wednesday the 1
probably another 10: a.m. sure sound
good yeah
okay so we will eventually move this
to Wednesday November 1st at 10: a.m.
and I yep
yes just you you've made reference to
the a number of things that you guys
specifically want to make sure gets
changed out of here could would you be
willing to just give me a sample of one
line doesn't have to be many of one
thing you'd like change just so that I
can have a greater understanding other
than like the broad idea but just just
so that I can help work on preparing for
next
week uh page two starting line 16 of the
original Bill all the striking out
wordage of processing preparing the
included I basically eliminated the
entire in my head the uh wait I'm Sor so
on the original
Bill not the Amendments yes so page two
line 16 XA drug paraphernalia okay yes
sorry this was me and this is not their
thoughts they have their own but I
wanted to delete all of that because
that is in in essence changing the
definition of 38 B1 which is drug
paraphernalia this is where I started to
have in my mind the back door for the uh
the dealers to be able to use this I had
thought about maybe eliminating that and
then putting it in with maybe even the
the fentel bill that just passed fentel
strips that except for and again I don't
know the verbiage off the top of my head
but that's where I was looking forward
to maybe put it in with that so that
this 318 B1 would not penalize the
person who wishes to use the test
materials but it would still punish the
nefarious characters okay and you we can
go representative re or representative
pro thank you no that that helps thank
you I have an issue with the very last
page um Roman numeral
five with all of that included in the
amendment in the in the in the amendment
the this one right
here I don't know if Muse gave you that
yeah there you go last page um it said
Roman numeral five
um there's just um a lot in there that I
think um would end up hurting the person
uh the substance abuser as a and helping
um the nefarious characters and I will
refine that for our next
meeting um and all the all the words
included in the drug paraphernalia
there's but primarily that caught my
eye your turn I'm good for
now does that somewhat help yes sorry
yes thank you so much I just for me
talking up here makes it really hard and
I it it's helpful to me to have some
concrete steps to look at yeah I I was
in the same boat I'm looking at it
putting it down walking away coming back
like I was like a mad man with this bill
like I want this to work but then I'm
I'm tolling like which way do I go I
don't want the bad guys coming in but I
want people to live so that's where in
my head I was really like circling but
let's make this work uh one last Quick
I I just want to thank you again I know
that at the beginning of our
conversation today there was a sort of
set we're going to end with this result
and I appreciate that we've shifted from
that to having a conversation to looking
at how we can have true bipartisanship
for the greater good of New Hampshire
rather than for any one individual so
thank you absolutely and I will hereby
close this subcommittee work session on
House Bill